Die chinesische weltraumbehörde hat die kontrolle über ihr labor tiangong 1 verloren die raumstation bewegt sich seit märz
2016 unkontrolliert auf die erde zu jetzt steht endlich genauer fest wann die stationen auf die erde stürzen wird doch selbst durch die
Verbesserten informationen können immer noch keine genauen vorhersagen gemacht werden also wie ist die lage
Jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Weltraumschrott beschäftigt uns ja immer wieder aber die anfang ein system besonders großer brocken übersetzt heißt die erste chinesische
Nicht dauerhaft bemannte raumstation so viel wie himmlischer palast
8,5 tonnen schwer etwa, so groß wie ein linienbus und
ausgestattet mit einem 14 kubikmeter großen labor sowie einer kleinen wohn ecke für die besucher von jcom1
den letzten jahren hat das raumlabor mehrere kopplungsmanöver mit
chinesischen raumschiffen der schanze
Reihe hinter sich gebracht doch schon 2016 verankerung 1 wohl außer kontrolle geraten china kann das labor schon seit märz
2016 nicht mehr steuern die folge rang eins bewegt sich seitdem
unkontrolliert auf die erde zu im oktober kreis in die station nach chinesischen berechnungen wohl noch in einer mittleren
Höhe von etwa 3 111 kilometern, im mai. Davor waren es noch
350 kilometer und jetzt sind es nur noch
212 kilometer
Regelmäßig gibt es dazu status updates aus china ab einer. Höhe von 200 kilometern wird die station deutlich schneller durch den luftwiderstand
abgebremst und das steht jetzt ganz kurz bevor jetzt gibt es aktuelle berechnungen wonach teile der chinesischen raumstation
Schon bald auf die erde stürzen werden das zeitfenster wird immer enger und es wird jetzt zwischen dem
30 märz und dem zweiten april liegen das hat die esa die europäische weltraumagentur berechnet es ist nicht das erste
mal dass wir uns mit, weltraumschrott
Beschäftigen müssen weil er auf kollisionskurs mit der erde ist vielleicht erinnert sich der eine oder andere von euch
1991 viele bruchstücke der sowjetischen raumstation zeigen 7 auf argentinien erhöht
menschen wurden nicht verletzt
weltraum experten und expertinnen fordern immer wieder dass ausgediente stationen und satelliten direkt
Im weltraum recycelt werden anstatt sie weiter mehr oder minder unkontrolliert auf die erde stürzen zu lassen
für django 1 gilt dass auf jeden fall nicht
Im september 2011 hat china tagung 1 ins all geschickt und jetzt nach sieben jahren
40 stationen mit ihren 8,5 tonnen gewicht auf die erde eigentlich sollte sie
kontrolliert zum absturz gebracht werden aber dann brach der funkkontakt ab die station ist nicht mehr steuerbar und stürzt jetzt eben unkontrolliert auf die erde
Dabei wird ein aus teil verglühen aber 30
Wahrscheinlich nicht alles was aus edelstahl oder titan gefertigt ist wird unweigerlich auf der erde landen zwei bis drei tonnen
Dürfen dass. Im fall von tiangong 1 seien doch das risiko getroffen zu werden
scheint extrem gering zu sein zitat die
wahrscheinlichkeit von einem trümmerteil verletzt zu werden ist so hoch wie die möglichkeit zwei mal in einem jahr von einem blitz getroffen zu werden so
holger krag von der esa bislang wurde noch kein mensch von einem trümmerteil getroffen
Es gibt einfach zu viel wasser und wüsten auf der erde und dort stürzen jedes jahr achtung
70 bis 80 tonnen weltraumschrott
Auf die erde so holger krag, im spiegel war und das finde
Ich jetzt echt schon noch eine menge aber bisher ist es ja noch gut gegangen aber. Wo die stationen jetzt runter
gehen wird das kann auch heute noch niemand sagen
Sie umrundete die erde in nur 90 minuten das heißt dass nur wenige minuten darüber entscheiden
Wo sie genau herabstürzt nur eins ist sicher hier in deutschland sind wir auf keinen fall betroffen auf mallorca
da könnte sich schon stürzen denn sie pendelt über die erde zwischen dem 43 grad südlich und dem
43 grad nördlich und überall zwischen diesen beiden
breitengraden kann die raumstation abstürzen erst quasi nur wenige stunden und dann genauer
Minuten vor dem absturz kann die genaue stelle bestimmt werden wobei stelle ist auch so eine
Sache es wird damit gerechnet dass die trümmer in einem
50 kilometer breiten streifen mit einer länge von bis zu
1200 kilometern auf die erde prasseln werden sobald ich etwas weiß wer sich auf whatsapp
schicken da erreichen euch die nachrichten da sofort und garantiert wenn er also nichts verpassen wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir auch vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen
Und mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier drauf liegen und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufdrücken
Weltraumschrott das ende der raumfahrt droht ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran